New Claude update is insane.
Claude just dropped a new update and it
is insane. It is completely free. It
remembers everything about you now. And
the craziest part, you can steal your
entire brain from chat GPT and feed it
to Claude in 60 seconds. I am going to
show you exactly how. Let us get into
it. So, here is what just happened.
Anthropic, the company behind Claude,
just flipped a switch. They turned on
memory for every single user. free plan,
no catch, no subscription, nothing. You
just get it. And if you have been using
chat GPT or Gemini and you have built up
all this context, all your preferences,
all your project history, Claude now
lets you bring all of that over like
moving houses, but for your AI brain and
it takes less than a minute. I am not
exaggerating. This is one of the biggest
AI updates we have seen this year and
nobody is talking about it. So stick
around because I am going to break down
exactly what changed, how to use it, and
why this might make you switch your main
AI tool today. But first, let me explain
why this matters so much. Think about
it. Every time you start a new chat with
an AI, what happens? You explain who you
are. You explain what you do. You
explain how you like things written. You
explain your projects. You do this over
and over and over again. Is like meeting
someone new every single day who has
zero memory of you. Imagine if your
assistant at work forgot who you were
every morning. You would you would lose
your mind. That is what AI has been like
until now. Claude memory means Claude
remembers you. It remembers your name.
It remembers your tone. It remembers
your projects. It remembers how you like
things done. So when you open a new
chat, it already knows you. It is like
having an assistant who actually paid
attention. And the best part, this is
not locked behind anything anymore. Free
users get this. That is a massive deal.
And honestly, most people have no idea
this even exists yet. So, you are
already ahead just by watching this
video. Hey, if we have not met already,
I am the digital avatar of Julian
Goldie, CEO of Goldie Agency. Whilst he
is helping clients get more leads and
customers, I am here to help you get the
latest AI updates. Julian Goldie reads
every single comment. So, make sure you
comment below and let him know what you
think about this update. Okay, so let me
walk you through the import feature
because this is where it gets really
wild. Go to Claude, open up settings,
then go to capabilities, then memory,
then import memory. Claude gives you a
prompt. You copy that prompt. You go
over to chat GPT or Gemini or whatever
AI you've been using. You paste that
prompt in. Your old AI spits out a
memory summary block. It is basically a
summary of everything it knows about
you. Your preferences, your tone, your
workflows, your project context, all of
it. You copy that block. You go back to
Claude. You paste it in. Done. Claude
now knows you like your old AI did. Your
first conversation with Claude feels
like your hundth. No rebuilding, no
reexplaining, no starting from scratch.
It is literally a copype job. 60
seconds. That is it. Now, let me slow
down here because I want you to really
understand how powerful this is. Before
this update, if you wanted to switch
from chat GPT to Claude, you had to
start completely from zero. All those
months of training your AI gone. All
those preferences you set up, gone. All
that context about your business, your
clients, your writing style, gone. It
was like wiping a hard drive and
starting over. Nobody wants to do that.
So, people just stayed where they were,
even if a better tool came along. That
barrier is now completely gone. You can
switch in 60 seconds and lose nothing.
That changes everything. And here is
something else that makes this even more
exciting. The way Claude handles memory
is actually really smart. It does not
just dump everything into one big messy
file. It organizes your context in a way
that makes it useful. So when you ask
Claude something, it pulls the right
memory at the right time. It is not like
having a notebook with random scribbles.
It is more like having a super organized
filing cabinet that knows exactly what
you need before you even ask. That is
the difference between memory that
exists and memory that actually works.
Now, here is why this is so smart from
Anthropic. The biggest reason people do
not switch AI tools is because they have
invested so much time training their
current one. You've spent months
teaching chat GBT, how you talk, what
you work on, what you like. Switching
feels like throwing all that away.
Anthropic just removed that problem
entirely. They said, "Bring it all with
you." The switching barrier just went to
zero. And that is genius because now
there is no reason not to try Claude.
You lose nothing. You bring everything.
Now, I want to talk about something
important. If you are serious about
using AI to grow your business and you
want to stay ahead of updates like this
one, you need to check out the AI profit
boardroom. It is the best place to scale
your business, get more customers, and
save hundreds of hours with AI
automation. If you want to learn how to
use tools like Claude Memory to actually
streamline your workflows and get real
results, that is where you need to be.
Link is in the description and the
comments. Go check it out. All right,
let us keep going. So, what should you
actually import when you use this
feature? Here is what I recommend.
First, your tone preferences. If you
have trained chat GBT to write in a
certain style, bring that over. Claude
will match it. Second, your work
projects. If you have ongoing clients,
campaigns, content calendars, whatever
it is, import that context. Third, your
tools and workflows. If your AI knows
you use specific software or follow
certain processes, bring that knowledge
over too. This saves you so much time
because Claude does not have to learn
you from zero. Now, what should you not
import? Do not import passwords. Do not
import sensitive personal information.
Do not import private secrets. Use
common sense here. This is an AI tool.
Treat it like one. Keep the useful
stuff. Leave the private stuff out.
Think of it like packing for a move. You
bring the furniture and the good stuff.
You leave the junk behind. And here is
another way to think about it. If you
are a content creator, imagine Claude
already knowing your YouTube style, your
audience, your niche, your past video
topics. You sit down to plan your next
video and Claude is already 10 steps
ahead because it remembers everything
from before. You skip the warm-up. You
skip the setup. you go straight to the
good stuff. That is what memory does. It
removes the friction between you and
getting things done. Let me tell you why
I think this is a gamecher for anyone
who uses AI for work. I run a team of 50
people. We use AI every single day.
Every time a new team member starts
using a new AI tool, there is this ramp
up period where they have to teach the
AI everything about our processes. With
memory import, that ramp up disappears.
You set it up once and Claude just knows
that is hours saved every single week.
Multiply that across a team and you are
looking at massive efficiency gains. We
are talking about getting more done in
less time with less effort. That is the
whole point. And here is another thing
people are not thinking about
competition.
This move by Anthropic
puts serious pressure on OpenAI and
Google because now users can leave and
take their context with them. That has
never been possible before. You were
locked in. Your AI knowledge was trapped
inside one platform. Not anymore.
Claude just opened the door and said,
"Come on in and bring your stuff." That
changes the whole game.
It forces every AI company to be better
because users can leave whenever they
want without losing anything. And as
users, that is exactly what we want.
More competition means better tools for
all of us. This update is a big deal. It
makes AI more personal, more useful, and
more accessible. And the fact that it is
free means everyone can benefit from it
right now. Not next month, not next
year, right now. Go to Claude, turn on
memory, import your context, and watch
how much better your AI experience gets
overnight. Now, if you want to take this
even further and you are serious about
using AI to grow your business, join the
AI Profit Boardroom. It is the best
community to learn how to use Clawed
Memory and tools like it to automate
your workflows, get more customers, and
scale faster with AI. If you want to
know exactly how to set up Clawude
Memory for your specific business and
get step-by-step SOPs, that is where you
need to be. link is in the description
and the comments. And if you want the
full process, SOPs, and over a 100 AI
use cases like this one, join the AI
success lab. Links in the comments and
description. You will get all the video
notes from there, plus access to our
community of 38,000 members who are
crushing it with AI. Make sure you
subscribe, hit the bell, and comment
below. Julian reads every single
comment. Let him know if you are going
to try Clawude Memory. I will see you in
the next